Hey guys, Pete here. Today I'm back with
another Dark season 3 video. I've been
rewatching the final season to add to my
notes, and today I have 33 details that
you might have missed.
I think 33 is the right number, but it's
a big number, so I want to jump right in.
Before we get started though I've got to
state the obvious, that this video will
contain spoilers if you haven't finished
watching dark season 3 yet. now we can
get started. Number 1 is that
everything's mirrored in alt Martha's
world. I had a lot of comments asking
about why the scratch on Martha's cheek
moved from side to side in different
scenes. the answer is that the creators
use this as a mark to indicate which
world we're in. it's not just that either
everything is mirrored including the
interiors of the homes, and the exterior
of places like the cave. this leads me
to believe that they essentially flipped
the shots after filming them, and what's
crazy about that is that they would have
to dress the sets in reverse. think about
this shot with Magnus and Martha and how
all the print on the stuff in the
background and his tattoos would have to
be reversed to achieve the effect. in the
origin world things like Martha's scratch
and the part in Jonas' hair match
Adam's world. and since we're on the
subject of the origin world the next two
items on the list pertain to that. number
two is that there's no power plant in
the origin world. in this shot we can see
that the smokestacks are noticeably
missing. it makes sense that if the
Unknown doesn't exist in the origin
world and therefore never forces through
the paperwork, that the coal lobby would
be able to block the power plant from
being built. number three is that they
use a different aspect ratio when we
visit that world to set it apart. we see
that the black bars above and below
the image are slightly larger and the
color grading seems brighter. since they
already used a mirror effect for Adam
and Eva's worlds they needed a different
visual clue to help mark where we were.
there are a few subtle differences
thrown in like the location of the bus
stop and the different door on the
entrance to the bunker as well. number
four speaking of things that look the
same but different, Dark has always done
a terrific job of casting actors who
resemble each other to portray
characters showing up at different ages
through the story. season 3 is no
exception and this time they even cast
some
real-life father and sons. for the adult
Unknown and the older version they cast
Jacob and Hans Diehl who clearly have a
family resemblance. the one that really
blew me away though was the character
they cast to portray a teenage Peter
Doppler. for this they cast Stephan Kampwirth's real-life son Pablo Striebek for
the part. I love the way they set up this
scene and I literally yelled out, "Its Peter!"
when he turned to the camera.
number five is about another great scene
in Episode two when Elizabeth and
Charlotte are together in the cave.
Charlotte gets up to walk away and as
she goes Elizabeth tells her everything
will be okay. this pair who are each
other's mother then come together to
comfort each other which is a callback
to season 1 when they did the same thing.
number 6 is also about Charlotte and
Elisabeth because I've had a lot of
questions related to these two.
first it was assumed that Claudia was
the one who stole baby Charlotte away
from Noah and Elisabeth. we learned in
episode 7 that Adam actually sent older
Charlotte and older Elisabeth to take
her to Tannhaus. in his conversation
with teenager Charlotte we learned a
couple more things as well. he tells her
about the strange women who showed up at
his door with her. he tells her on that
same day his son and his wife died in a
car crash with his granddaughter, and
that the baby's body was never found.
because of that he was able to pass off
Charlotte who was brought to him from
the future as his real granddaughter. so
in the scene when he tells her about
that she's learning for the first time
that they aren't related by blood and
that he has no idea who her real parents
are. the story of the Doppler family keeps
getting crazier, but the couple from
number 7 actually managed to outdo them.
that is of course Martha and Jonas who
we learned are the center of the family
tree knot that is Winden. Jonas and alt
Martha have a child together and things
get really interesting from there. their
son who appears as a trio of characters
at three different ages doesn't have a
name so he's referred to as the Unknown.
after he's born he impregnates both
Agnes Nielsen's in both worlds which
connects everyone beyond that back to
Jonas and Martha. the male line goes Jonas >
Unknown > Tronte > Ulrich > Mikkel > Jonas. so if
you're keeping track that makes
Jonas his own
great-great-great-grandfather.
another interesting detail here is the
couple is really the beginning and the
end of things. they start the knot and
then later undo it when they travel to
the origin world where none of their
descendants exist. speaking of mr. Kahnwald
number eight is this shot of him
dying in Eva's world. the way he's laying
on the ground makes the family tree look
like angel wings and that's interesting
since Tannhaus' daughter-in-law Sonja
mentions angels after Jonas and Martha
stopped them from getting into the car
crash. he's dying on the floor of Eva's
lair and number nine is the name of her
group. Adam's world has Sic Mundus and
Eva's has Erit Lux which translates to
there will be light. we see this on the
metal door to the passage in her world.
number ten is Erit Lux's symbol which
is two snakes with wings. this is called
a caduceus symbol and what you might
have missed is that Magnus has a tattoo
of this above his sternum. for number
eleven will stay on Eva and her lair. you
might have missed that her family tree
is actually wrong. it has Tronte listed
as Regina's father which was the popular
theory heading in the season. three it
turned out that Claudia and Bernd Doppler
were Regina's parents and what's
interesting about this is that Claudia
was probably deceiving Eva since she's
likely the only person who knew the
truth. number twelve is also related to
parentage at the end of episode six when
Eva is sending her travelers back to
preserve the loop she tells Egon to
create his past to preserve the family
tree. a lot of people have been asking
about this so this is my understanding.
in Eva's world Hannah is married to
Ulrich and pregnant with his child at
the time of the apocalypse. just before
the older Egon arrives she suffers a
miscarriage. we know they are still Silja's
parents in both worlds but her path
is different since she hasn't traveled
to the 1950s. this leads me to believe
that Egon will take her there to save
her from the apocalypse and that will
put her in place to meet the younger
Egon and start their affair. on the
subject of Silja number 13 is the look
on Bartosz's face when he hears that
she wants to name their son Hanno.
remember Noah
aka Hanno Tauber is the one who brought
Bartosz into this mess in
first place. so at this moment he would
be realizing that he was meeting with
his own son. what makes us even more
insane is that we know that Noah kills
his own father in the opening of season
two. number fourteen is another Silja
one and it's something I didn't notice
myself. I got this one from Kim Renfro's
great "things you might have missed
article" on The Insider website. Kim is
one of my favorite writers because she
always digs deep, and you can tell she's
a fan. I will put a link to her
article in this video's description
because she includes a lot of stuff from
the first and second season. anyway Kim
pointed out that Silja is wearing the
same clothes she had Martha take off
in the future when she arrives back in
1890 to get together with Bartosz. number
15 deals with that same time period. one
of the biggest questions about Jonas's
story was how he transformed into the
stranger and then later Adam. what a
revelation it is to find out just how
lame that process actually was for him.
we see that he's stuck in post
apocalyptic Winden after surviving the
actual apocalypse. unable to go anywhere
because Eva is making Claudia stall her
progress on stabilizing the god particle.
then he goes to do the things we saw him
do in the first two seasons only to get
stuck in 1888 working to build the god
particle twin. what struck me the most
about this was that we had been
wondering how he got his trademark
scarring. my takeaway after season 3 is
that this is a combination of injuries
we see him get burnt at one point and
that makes me believe that instead of
being scarred from time traveling
extensively it's actually more of a
death from a thousand paper cuts kind of
situation. number 16 is one that goes
back even before 1888. we learn about the
origin of the golden watch. several
people asked why'd the blind man, who
turns out to be Gustav Tannhaus, had the
watch in the scene where he's killed by
the Unknown? the answer is that the watch
was passed down from his father,
Heinrich Tannhaus, who originally bought
it for his wife who was named Charlotte.
she died and this led to the formation
of Sic Mundus because Heinrich wanted to
learn about time travel to try to go
back and save her life. the name
Charlotte and the idea of time
travelling to save a departed loved
one will continue on in the
Tannhaus family throughout the
generations. number 17 is another one
that I got from Kim's article and it's
about Magnus. when he's in front of the
cave in the 2019 timeline he says
something to the effect of about a
hundred years, just after the war they
did experiments in the caves. this is
interesting because that would be around
the time where Erit Lux would probably
be doing the same things that sic Mundus
was doing at the beginning of season two.
digging the passage and getting ready
for it to open up years later. the next
five are all bits of deja vu and they
start off with the experience that Martha
and alt Martha have under the bridge
and the opening episodes of season 1 and
season 3. next we saw Bartosz in class
talking about wormholes which felt like
a callback to seeing the classroom in
season 1. in that scene the teacher was
talking about symmetry and said the
repetition is mirrored along a central
axis. so the repetition begins at an
imaginary center point and branches off
into opposing directions. there was an
interesting drawing that looks like the
two worlds and the infinity knot on the
board so this is an early reference to
how things played out in the final
season. the next one is another one from
school and it's the actor who played
Killian showing up in season one. he was
in their school's version of the play
Ariadne. he wasn't credited as being an
Obendorf in season one and this was
his only scene, but it was played by the
same actor and it's connected to the
same situation. number 21 is Ulrich
mentioning the Apocalypse both times
when he was coming back from the bakery
because he was out having an affair. in
season 1 he's held up because he's
spending time with Hannah and in season 3
he's telling Hannah that he was held up
because he was spending time with
Charlotte. number 22 is Eva repeating
Adam's line about a person living three
lives. while it's not word for word it is
a variation and a call back to Adam
talking with Jonas. the basic gist is
that the first life ends with the loss
of naivete, the second with the loss of
innocence, and the third with the loss of
life itself. number 23 is that we hear
about the phenomenon that Eva exploits
for her loophole on the radio in 2020.
Claudia is
walking into the post-apocalyptic police
station where she lives and we can hear
the radio. we hear scientists are still
looking for an explanation for the
events of June 27 2020 the presumed
origin of the catastrophe is assumed to
be the small town of Winden. the woman
continues, "a French team of scientists
believe it's possible that our world
Stood Still for a fraction of a
nanosecond On June 27th." so later in the
season 3 finale we find out that Claudia
learned how to use that to create a
second reality and go to speak with Adam
and get him to send Jonas and Martha to
the origin world. number 24 is that
Regina now lives in the house that was
the Kahnwald house in Adam's world and
the Nielsen's house in Eva's world. this
is pretty interesting when you think
about it the main character lived in
this house in all three worlds. number 25
is the world without Winden question
that Regina asks is a callback. remember
she said if the world were to end today
and you only had one wish what would you
wish for? Katharina thinks about that and
says a world without Winden let's drink
to that. I mentioned that this is a
callback to teen Ulrich and Hannah's
conversation at the bus stop in season 1
episode 3 in my ending explained video
so check that video out if you haven't
seen it yet and you want to know more
about that conversation. number 26 is
that Torben and Hannah are married in
the origin world her name is actually
listed in the family tree as Hannah
Woller. this makes you think about the
comment that he made to Clausen when he
said she was so pretty she could have
had any man she wanted. it's a nice
little easter egg to set up this
relationship. number 27 is also related
to Clausen and that's that the letter
he received is almost definitely written
by the Unknown. inside the letter it said
he that has eyes to see and ears to hear
may convince himself that no mortal can
keep a secret. in season 3 we hear the
Unknown used that same language which
actually comes from Sigmund Freud when
he's talking to the older blind Tannhaus.
the next two are both related to
music the first is that the Nena song
Irgendwie, Irgendwo, Irgendwann,
which we first
hear in Mads' cassette recorder, and it
pops up several times throughout the
series, is the song they closed out the
last episode with. the title translates
in English to somehow somewhere sometime
and it has a real connection to what our
characters go through. number 31 is
another music related one and that's
that the version of what a wonderful
world we hear during Jonas and Martha's
last scene is performed by the artist
Soap&Skin. she also performs the
vocal track in the song "Goodbye" by
Apparat played over the opening
credits. so if the voice sounded familiar
you can now connect the dots. number 32
is about the pendant on the beach. we saw
when Katharina is killed by her own
mother that she takes it from her.
remember her mother got it from Hannah
when they were at the abortion clinic.
she kept that all her life and then when
she was killing her own daughter
Katharina managed to pull it off. that got
left on the beach and years later
Jonas and Martha will find it. number 33
and the last one on this list is the
story of the lady in the lake that was
referred to in season 2. so we know
Katharina she traveled back in time to
try to rescue her son Mikkel and her
husband Ulrich.
I just mentioned that she was killed by
her own mother and then her body was
dragged into the lake. years later when
they're swimming Bartosz tells the story
of the lady in the lake that a woman's
body was found at the bottom of the
water. what's crazy about this is that
Katharina was the woman and Bartosz is
telling the story to Martha her daughter
to try to scare her. Magnus is also there
and it's a really sad way to end
Katarina story and that is the entire
list. I just talked to her a long time so
I'm gonna bring it to an end let me know
how many of these you caught how many of
these you didn't see any other ones that
you picked up on that I didn't include
when I thought about the number 33 I
thought I might have to add some things
to get enough it turned out to be the
other way actually I was able to think
of more some of them I combined and some
of them I just whittled down to get us
to 33 because that's pushing the limits
for how long I like to make a video in
the first place so please like this
video if you enjoy
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already let me know in the
comments if there's any other dark
videos you want to see I'll be doing
more this week thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon